un univers une voix une attitude à part
dans le monde du show-business un an et
demi après son dernier album intitulé
l'imprudence alain bashung nous propose
aujourd'hui un double cd live et double
dvd restitution de la tournée des grands
espaces à 31 titres dans le double album
alain vachon bonsoir vous avez entamé
cette tournée il ya quelques mois vous
serez lundi à l'olympia
comment vivez-vous d'être sur scène
aujourd'hui après huit ans d'absence
comment je le vis je le vis très
intensément parce que j'ai un peu de
gêne un peu de temps à rattraper
n'attrapez pendant pendant ces huit
années vous vous n'aviez plus le désir
de vous montrer physiquement d'être sur
un plateau
oh c'est pas tout à fait sage et j'ai
participé à quelques films ou d'autres
projets discographiques avec d'autres
artistes parfois mais non disons que
j'avais envie de
de venir sur scène avec une espèce de
avec des quelque chose qui ressemblerait
à des images enfin quelque chose qui
pourrait raconter un petit peu mes
fantasmes et pousser un petit peu plus
loin le simplement le fait de jouer avec
l'orchestré être là il montrait un peu
l'univers peut te blier mélanger le son
les images passent effectivement l'image
est très présent surtout sur trois
panneaux
durant le spectacle oui on sait c'est
milan je voulais mélanger tout ça à le
faire une fois vraiment comme j'avais
envie et pas seulement avec des avec des
clichés pop mais plutôt avec des avec
des gens que j'ai rencontrés abandonné
qui en fait viennent soit du théâtre ou
des arts plastiques
donc ça ça donne et des combines des
combinaisons qui font que un mélange
nouveau avec lewis est assez c
je connais pas tellement ou et de choses
comme ça mais donc je vais vous même du
mal à le qualifier
oui oui oui parce que je l aimais
beaucoup si les trouver des mots vous ne
sauriez pas quel qualificatif m sur fait
alors justement c'est assez difficile
ça peut venir je sais je peux vous pour
avoir compté le début m'a alors c'est
toute une histoire ces des rencontres ou
des voyages à venise venise m'avait créé
sous l'impression curieux je le voyais
je ne voyais n'y avait pas de signes
d'avenir et la chine ou si j'avais
tourné un film en chine qui doit le
tournage m'avait beaucoup marqué je
voyais ce parfois un lien entre la chine
et venise ce marco polo vous avez voulu
mettre ces images dans ce spectacle oui
parce qu'en fait c'est une sorte de
géographie l'esprit c'est ça avoir avec
nos fonctionnements avec les grands
espaces c'est peut-être ce qui nous
manque ici mais quand ha oui quelque
chose face à voir avec ce qu'on a dans
la tête je suis ouvert et du fils et
fiat et plus oui vous voir plus loin
peut-être c'est pour l'instant on a on
apprend sur l'impression que mon but sur
d'anciens problèmes encore
alors on a peur de se projeter dans le
futur un peu il ya un peu de ça
en tout cas la nuit vous mentez c'est ce
que vous dites dans cette chanson
magnifique j'avoue il manque dans les
coups très belle chanson
je me remettra à travers la pêche
je vends la même
j'adore les modes des montagnes de
questions où subsistent encore
comme toujours
j'ai fait la saison dans cette boîte
crânienne
penser je ne faisais mien
barret
magalas
écrire une chanson comme félicia lama
choquant vient l'inspiration
d'abord j'ai fait toutes ces chansons
avec des partenaires parfois donc on se
bagarre depuis je sais des rapports
d'amitié ma porte parfois les des pages
et des pages
jusqu'au moment où je je je me dis à une
demi-ligne quelque part que tu pourras
me tellement c'est parfois ses rentrées
17 euros c'est pas une exigence faux
j'ai une vague idée parfois de du
résultat final ça les russes je sais ce
que je sais à peu près ce que je
pourrais assumer où je sais tout ce que
j'ai déjà raconté
ou comment je vais raconter donc j'ai un
peu danger un peu le besoin de raconter
autrement ou de le formuler autrement
alors tout ça comme je le sais j'ai pas
non plus envie de de me mordre la queue
trop alors c'est assez pratique de
travailler avec quelqu'un qui en fait
est un peu en dehors de votre esprit
mais qui peut rejoindre
préoccupations alors aujourd'hui vous
êtes depuis d'ailleurs longtemps adulé
par la critique par le public comment
est ce que vous vivez cette
reconnaissance succès ce que c'est
quelque chose que vous avez intégré
depuis vos trente ans et l'âge de gaby
ou où ça reste quelque chose d'un peu
abstrait pour vous ça me touche quand
même parce que j'ai l'impression que on
communique quelque chose qui vient échos
quand même et puis je suis assez fier du
fait que ça puisse être reçue alors que
c'est pas très explicite
c'est ce n'est pas forcément facile et
je partouche ce quelque chose d'un peu
surréaliste parfois donc on va en avoir
un deuxième extrait avec angora osez
joséphine et ma petite entreprise
écouter
le souffle coupé la gorge irritée jeu
mais pour monnaie sans broncher
angora entre mois d'où vient la vie vont
les ex au bout dit
ce jeu
posez vous
le royaume se pose
huma abedin
je suis
or cette idée
pour
je vais vous définissiez comme autiste
compositeur pour quand vous ayez du mal
à communiquer ça m'arrive d'être
complètement bloquée oui c'est difficile
de parler en public de parler là devant
une caméra par exemple non c'est pas
très facile quand lorsqu'il s'agit d'une
conversation et je ne pense pas
forcément à une réponse immédiate
oui ça ne peut que ça ça va à peu près
mais ça c'est pas trop grave c'est les
cheveux est autiste avec des gens j'ai
n'ai pas peur du silence de rester dans
votre univers
moi je n'ai pas peur du silence mais les
pop un peu un peu expliqué bizarrement
la notion de silence moi ça me dérange
pas de rester silencieux alors ici on va
pas le faire connaître les derniers mots
vous dites aussi que vous travaillez
moins sur la musique sur les sentiments
qu'elle procure
ça veut dire quoi c'est que vous n'êtes
pas technicien vous est d'abord un
intuitive vous êtes un gg oui oui j'ai
plutôt intuitive sais pas je n'ai pas
fait conservatoire mais par contre j'ai
c'est vrai que je me suis intéressé à
beaucoup de formes de musique ou
d'écriture aussi donc
après j'ai essayé de de faire ça à la
fois sérieusement et en même temps avec
beaucoup de recul et aujourd'hui
c'est plus pour provoquer une émotion -
pendant le moment pendant lequel je je
je n'ai je navigue chercher oui oui
alors en tout cas je rappelle la tournée
des grands espaces double cd live double
dv la dvd live et puis lundi lundi soir
vous êtes à l'olympia donc pour tous les
fans de bashung
à ne pas rater merci d'être venu nous
voir on passe un autre genre de musique